Good evening and welcome
to the penultimate lecture
in this year's lecture
series on cosmology.
Just to remind you, the universe
is 13.7 billion years old.
Hydrogen, helium and lithium
were formed in the Big Bang.
All of us are 90% stardust.
And today we're going to
talk about black holes.
I want to thank our
underwriters, the Arizona Daily
Star, Cox
Communication, Bob Davis
in Innovation Park, Innovation
Place, Stantec, DPR, Bob.
Our Galileo Circle
members, Godat Design,
Raytheon, Research Corporation
for Science and Advancement,
UniSource Energy and
Ventana Medical Systems.
Obviously, it's not
parking and transportation.
I want to remind you before
I introduce our speaker
tonight that we do
have, for those of you
interested in astronomy,
we do have a sky center
on top of Mount Lemmon with some
pretty spectacular telescopes.
And here what you see
is in fact a picture
that was awarded by NASA
the picture of the day.
It's a picture of the NGC 1999,
a nebula that is currently
forming stars in the
constellation of Orion.
So in addition to the
highly acclaimed sky nights,
and you can buy pictures like
this from Adam Block, who
I think is back there,
in addition to the highly
acclaimed sky night
program, the sky center
is offering a companion
series to this cosmic origins.
And Phil Pinto, for those of
you that missed his lecture,
will be there April 1st.
So I urge you to go
up to Mount Lemmon.
Take your boots and
all your heavy clothes
and enjoy the telescopes.
It is my pleasure to introduce
today's speaker, Feryal Ozel.
She is an associate
professor in astronomy
whose research interests are
black holes, neutron stars,
structure formation,
and the reionization
of the early universe.
Her research has
received numerous prizes
and recognitions,
including the 2010 Bart Bok
prize from Harvard University
and the Lucas award.
Her work has been
supported by NASA and NSF,
totaling almost $1
million just in this year.
She is a frequent guest in
TV documentaries on PBS,
the History Channel,
CNN International,
as well as many scientific
articles in the popular press.
Feryal is often invited
as a keynote speaker
in international events for
the public and the industry,
such as the International
Innovation Day hosted
by Novartis, and the Middle
East Women's Literacy Campaign
launched by Louis Vuitton.
When she's not exploring the
far reaches of the universe,
she likes to push her
own limits by competing
in triathlons and marathons.
This past year, Feryal came
in second in the Wineglass
Marathon in New York,
and also climbed
Mount Kilimanjaro in Tanzania.
She says the skies
look absolutely amazing
at that altitude.
So Feryal, where are you?
Good evening.
And I would like to
welcome all of you
on this beautiful Tucson
evening to Centennial Hall.
I will tell you about black
holes and how we find them.
I would like to take you
on a journey of what it is
that we understand about them.
And I would like to tell you
how they push our understanding
of physics and gravity.
And I would also
like to tell you
that black holes are very
unique objects in the universe.
We only find them
through their influence
on their surroundings,
because we
don't have a direct way
of seeing them just yet,
because as the name
suggests, they are black.
I would also like to tell
you that despite everything
that we associate with them,
all the energetic phenomena, all
the general relativity,
complex mathematics,
and the various ways
in which we find them,
they are actually
fairly simple objects.
And they're at the same
time pretty extreme objects.
And I would also like to tell
you that they are everywhere.
We find them in our galaxy.
We find them in other galaxies
in the nearby universe.
And we find them when
we look far back in time
to the early universe.
But before I do all
of that, I don't
want to get ahead of myself.
I would like to tell you a
little bit about gravity, what
we understand about it,
how our understanding of it
developed over centuries,
and what are some challenges
that we face in understanding
the next frontiers.
What I'm about to
show you is a movie
of the solar system, which
is our first encounter
with gravity.
And in this movie,
if we had the luxury
of being far out in space, and
looking at the solar system way
beyond Neptune's orbit, this
is what it would look like.
And don't worry about
the fact that our sun
has become a red giant
at the end of this movie.
That's five billion years away.
And I'm pretty sure we'll
either destroy our planet
by other means by then, or we
will have found other habitable
planets to move to.
So not worrying
about that last bit,
let's look at what
the solar system,
our very first
experience with gravity,
has taught us over
the centuries.
So that takes us back
to the time of Kepler,
Johannes Kepler, in the 1500s.
He's the first
person to formulate
the motions of planets and
how they relate to how massive
the object at the center
of such a system should be.
At that time, the
heliocentric belief,
which is that the sun is at
the center of our solar system,
was fairly new.
It had no observational support.
But Kepler was one of
the first believers
of the heliocentric
point of view.
And not only that, but
he actually formulated
mathematically, as I said,
what the mass of the object
at the center of such
a system should be that
holds things in
motion around it.
This could be a
circular orbit, or it
could be a distorted circle,
such as an ellipse, as we
see in some of the planets
in our solar system.
And just looking at Kepler's
laws formulated in the 1500s
can tell us what is the source
of gravity that is keeping
all these planets in places.
In fact, Kepler has
been so influential,
one of the first figures
of scientific revolution,
that today we call
a Kepler problem
anything that involves orbiting,
planets, stars, et cetera.
It doesn't even
have to be a planet.
If a star orbits
around a black hole,
we still call it
a Kepler problem,
just because his laws are
applicable to those situations
as well.
Of course, it was Galileo's
observational support
that first provided the data for
the heliocentric point of view.
He didn't have the luxury
of what we just had,
stepping outside
of the solar system
and looking at a movie of
how everything is moving.
He constructed bits
and pieces of orbits.
He looked at phases of Venus.
He looked at the motions
of moons around Jupiter.
And because of the telescope
that he was able to build,
he actually collected
the first data
on the motion of the planets.
And then came Newton.
Newton was the
first person to say
that if these planets are
moving in circles or ellipses,
it must be that they are
held there by some force,
and he named it the
gravitational force.
He not only named
it, but he was also
able to formulate what
this force would look like.
So very simply what
he said is that there
is a constant that determines
the strength of this force,
but this force goes with the
mass of the central object that
is keeping the planets in place.
It goes with the
mass of the planet.
And it's reduced by
distance squared.
So the farther away two objects
are, the less the gravitational
pull is between them.
The more massive an
object is, the more
of a gravitational
influence it has.
That force is larger.
And this formulation is what
we used for several centuries
to understand the
gravitational force.
So is this it?
Can we go home?
Well, not really.
Newton's theory explained a lot
of the data that was available
back then, and most of it was
just the solar system data.
There was one little piece of
data that it couldn't explain,
and that was the so-called
precession of Mercury's orbit.
What does that mean?
So Mercury is the inner most
planet in the solar system.
It also happens to
be the planet that
has the most elliptical
orbit, the most distorted
from a circle.
Now when you have
an elliptical orbit,
can put the sun at one of the
focal points of this ellipse,
and then you can orient this
ellipse either this way,
or this way, or this way.
According to Newton, whatever
the orientation of that ellipse
was, it would not
change by much.
That was what the
classical theory predicted.
Except that what was observed
was that the orbit of Mercury
actually changed its
orientation with respect
to where the sun was.
In astronomical
terms, we call that
the precession of the orbit.
So this is something that
Newton's theory was not
able to explain.
Then came Einstein and
said you have it all wrong.
He actually said that gravity
is not a force at all.
He said we know of other forces.
We know of
electromagnetic force.
We know how things
stay in place.
But he said gravity is
actually not a force
but a geometric effect, and
he called that the distortion
of space and time.
Even though the precession
of Mercury's orbit
was known at the
time of Einstein,
that was not one of
Einstein's motivations.
He had other issues with
the physics theories
at the time that he
was trying to correct.
He was trying to make
those theories, especially
gravity, compatible
with his seminal work
on special relativity that
he had formulated in 1905.
But you might think, what
on earth does that mean?
What does it mean for space
and time to be distorted?
Where did time get
into all of this?
So I would like to show you
with pictures what actually that
means.
But first I would
like to actually
show you a copy of the paper
that he published in 1916 where
he first introduced the
theory of general relativity.
And that is the theory that
forms our understanding
of gravity today.
So he said gravity
is not a force.
It's not a force as
we understand it.
It doesn't actually have
an effect on other objects
because it pulls
them or pushes them.
So you might think,
that's pretty
contrary to my
experience, because when
I shoot a basketball, I know
that if there was no gravity,
it would go in a straight
line with the same speed
and direction with
which I shot it.
But I know that there is gravity
on Earth, so balls get curved.
A fastball gets curved a little
bit less than a slow ball.
So how are we going to
make this compatible
with our understanding?
Well, Captain Kirk would
say, this is a straight line.
It's just a warped spacetime,
and this is a straight line
in that warped spacetime.
So for a moment,
I would like you
to imagine that
you're little ants,
and I would like you
to imagine that you're
walking on rocks,
on fabrics, maybe
on the fabric of my jacket.
And you think that
you're going straight.
But the fabric underneath
itself is warped.
And this is what
Einstein is telling us,
that the mass
stretches and distorts
the fabric on which we
live, on which we measure
our time, on which we
walk straight lines,
and on which we
measure distances.
So again, looking
at the solar system,
if this is the sun at the
center of the solar system,
because of its mass,
because it weighs something,
the sun distorts the
fabric of spacetime
so that the Earth is actually
going in a straight line,
or rather it is trying
to go in a straight line,
but the straight line in
this warped space time
is the circle that
it traces out.
Now there are other
consequences of this.
Einstein said not only do
objects like ants and planets
move in straight lines
in this curved spacetime,
but so does light.
Light also feels the
exact same distortion
of the spacetime
fabric as we do.
So what that means is
that if we were looking
at a distant object and the sun
was between us and that object,
the light that came from
that distant object,
the actual position
of the star would
have to go in this distortion,
what we call the potential well
that the sun creates, and climb
back out and reach us on Earth,
and be visible to us, either to
our eyes or to our telescopes.
Now because it has gone
through this straight path
in this curved spacetime,
when we look at it in the sky,
we would actually think that the
light came from this direction.
So we would assume that we
should just extrapolate or make
this line of sight
longer, and we
would see the star over there.
Is this what happens?
Well, actually it very
much is what happens.
And this was the first real
triumph of Einstein's theory
of general relativity.
It happened in 1919
shortly after the end
of the First World War.
And it was Sir Arthur
Eddington who led an expedition
to look at the positions
of the stars behind the sun
during a solar eclipse.
And the reason that they did
this during a solar eclipse
is that the light of
the stars behind the sun
wouldn't be overpowered
by the sun's light
like it is normally
during the day.
So what they saw, even though
you can't see it very well
on this image, is that the
positions of the stars when
the sun was directly
in front of them
was actually different
than the same star
when the sun was
not in front of it.
So they measured the actual
displacement of various stars
in the sky during
the solar eclipse,
and it provided the
first real evidence
of how general relativity
was the correct description
of gravity.
In fact, it made the
headlines of the day.
This is just a small excerpt
from the New York Times cover
shortly after the expedition.
Men of science, more
or less agog over
results of eclipse observations.
It also goes on to
say that Einstein
thought that nobody understood
general relativity but him.
That's all bogus, but it
makes a good newspaper story.
Now with our modern telescopes,
we observe this phenomenon
that we call
gravitational lensing
everywhere in the universe.
So not only do distant
images of galaxies and stars
look like they're displaced
from their actual position,
but they also look distorted
because light travels
through different
paths to get to us.
And here is a famous
so-called blue arc,
which you can see here.
That was taken by
the Hubble Space
Telescope, our first
optical telescope in space.
That opened many new
frontiers for us.
And what you see here is
that this massive galaxy
cluster at the center
is in the line of sight
between a distant
galaxy and us on Earth.
So that massive galaxy
cluster actually
makes the light coming from
the distant galaxy travel
through its warped spacetime,
and we see multiple images
of it forming in the sky.
So what you see here
as this arc is actually
a single object
that is magnified
through a gravitational lens.
So let's take this gravitational
lensing, this distortion
of light one step further.
And that's where it's going
to lead us to black holes.
Black holes are the
ultimate gravitational lens.
That's one way to
think about it.
So what I mean here
is that if matter
or the distortions of
spacetime by matter
has the ability to make light
move in these straight paths
in this curved
spacetime, what happens
when that gravitational
field is really extreme?
It's not that of the sun,
which is, let's face it,
it's a pretty measly object.
It's not even that
of a galaxy cluster,
but it is something
with extreme gravity,
so that when light is trying to
pass through this distortion,
it actually loops
back onto itself.
In other words, it cannot escape
from this gravitational field.
If that happened, that
object would look dark,
because light would not
be able to actually leave
the vicinity of that
object and reach
a distant observer like we are.
We are actually familiar
with the concept of an escape
velocity from our daily lives.
If I had a ball here and
I threw it in the air,
I know that it would come back
down, because even though I run
marathons, I'm not
strong enough to have
a ball escape the gravitational
field of the earth.
But if I put a rocket
under that ball,
I know that I could generate
enough speed for that ball
to escape the gravitational
field of the earth, right?
We know that.
We have been able
to go to the moon
and even to further reaches
of the solar system.
So what we are saying
here is that let's think
of an object that is so
strong in its gravity
that in order to escape
its gravitational field
would take speeds that
exceed the speed of light.
Light is the fastest
thing in the universe,
and even that would not
be able to escape it.
There is another way to think
about strong gravitational
fields and black holes,
and that is possibly
a little closer to our
experience than this escape
velocity of light.
And what that says
is that, well,
if we're actually
little ants crawling
in this curved
fabric of spacetime,
it's kind of like
swimming in a river
or an ocean with very
strong currents or waves.
Now, if those currents or waves
are somewhat gentle like they
are up here for this
fish, then that fish
can swim with the current,
against the current,
or perpendicular to the current.
He has a little bit more
control of his destiny.
But if that current
is so strong,
and it's headed
towards a waterfall,
no matter how fast
this fish swims,
it's just going to move with
the current underneath it.
The motion of objects
around the black hole
are very much like
this fish trying
to escape its destiny
towards the waterfall.
And mathematically,
we describe it
with the concept
of a light cone.
Now, a light cone tells
us how with a given
distance from a
black hole-- let's
start with this
picture right here--
an object is allowed to move.
An object is not allowed to move
faster than the speed of light.
But beyond that, if you're
away from that waterfall which
we call the event
horizon for a black hole,
you are allowed to move in every
which direction that you want,
including away
from the waterfall.
So this is an observer
that is at a safe distance
from a black hole.
But as you get closer and
closer and closer, what you find
is that your destiny, your
light cone, your future
is actually headed
in to the black hole,
and there is no escape from it.
Now, that's great, maybe.
Einstein's general
relativity theory
is supported by a
lot of observations.
Maybe this logical
extreme of taking
that theory and gravitational
lensing to describe black holes
is OK.
But really, are
there black holes?
Is it in the realm
of science where
we can say this object that
we observed is a black hole?
Or is it really still
a theoretical concept
where we say, taking general
relativity to its limit, that's
what we find?
What I want to show you
next is a little story
of how we actually
find black holes,
because it's a
complicated story,
and it takes a lot of effort.
First and foremost, because the
objects themselves are black,
we can only view them
through their influence
on their surroundings.
So we have to be a
little bit lucky in order
to observe a black hole.
We want to observe
its stellar companion,
or stars that happen
to be in the vicinity,
in order to understand
what it does to that star.
In other words, we want to
solve the Kepler problem.
Instead of putting
the sun in the center,
we want to put the black
hole in the center,
and we want to look at what it
does to its stellar companion.
What we do is look at the sky
first with x-ray telescopes,
because even though they
themselves are dark,
because of their incredible
pull on their surroundings,
because of their ability
to strip stars of their gas
and matter and to swallow
them, they can actually produce
very energetic radiation.
And this radiation is visible
to us in the form of x-rays.
Now, our atmosphere
is opaque to x-rays,
which means it doesn't
let x-rays come through.
That's great for human beings,
not so good for astronomers.
If it doesn't come
through our atmospheres,
and we are here on earth
beneath our atmosphere,
it means that we won't be able
to see that kind of radiation.
And that's typically
the first clue for us
that there is a black hole,
what we call a black hole
candidate out there.
So what we do is put
x-ray telescopes in orbit
around the earth.
And here are two
beautiful x-ray telescopes
from the last decade, the
Chandra X-ray Observatory,
and the Rossi X-ray Timing
Explorer, both of which
have been real
champions in giving us
the first clues that there
might be a black hole,
either in our galaxy
or in another galaxy.
That's great.
We collected the
first piece of data
that makes us think
that there might
be a black hole out there.
But remember, we are
solving the Kepler problem.
We are not looking at
the black hole directly.
What we want to do is look
at the stellar companion that
is orbiting it, because
if we can see its orbit,
if we can see it wobbling around
this huge gravitational pull
that is caused by
the black hole,
then we can solve for its
orbit, and we can also
say how massive is the object
that is keeping it there.
In order to do that, we
turn our optical telescopes
to our black hole candidates.
This may not be the nicest
picture of the Magellan
Telescope you've seen,
but it is the picture
that I have taken on my
first trip to Magellan.
These are twin 6 and
1/2 meter telescopes
that were cast in our
very own mirror lab.
And they operate beautifully,
and the University of Arizona
is very lucky to have observing
time on these telescopes.
So one of the things that we do
is use the Magellan telescopes
to actually follow
the star that is
in orbit around the black hole.
So we're collecting
little bits and pieces
of data like coins in a jar.
And sometimes we even
bring in the big guns.
This is a picture of
the Very Large Array.
It's a radio telescope array
in Socorro, New Mexico.
And sometimes there is
additional bits of information
that come from the
radio observations,
such as how far is the
object that we're looking at.
We collect all these
pieces of data,
and we try to reconstruct what
it is that we are looking at.
What we find is
that we are looking
at something very massive.
So just like we can know
about how big the sun is just
by looking at the orbit of
Mercury, or orbit of the Earth,
or any of the other planets,
we can say with certainty
how big the object that is
keeping the star in orbit
is just by solving
the Kepler problem.
There is a little bit
of luck involved, too.
Sometimes the stars
don't wobble as much
as we would like them to.
So sometimes these series
of observations take years,
and it's a concerted effort
between different astronomers
in different institutions.
But when we are lucky, we
find something very massive.
It doesn't emit light by itself.
It is very dark.
But it pulls everything
in its environment
and typically produces
those energetic x-rays.
So we are almost there.
But being scientists,
we are cautious,
and we are always
questioning what we find.
Is it really a black
hole that we have seen?
There is one last question
that we have to ask ourselves
which is, is what we are
seeing a real black hole,
or could it be another
very dense object,
possibly very massive,
and maybe it's dark.
And those objects we
call neutron stars.
So in order to tell you
what a neutron star is,
I want to show you a very
schematic view of what
a star looks like, because this
star at the end of its lifetime
has the ability to turn into a
black hole or a neutron star.
During its lifetime,
there is nuclear reactions
going on at the center.
And for those of you who
attended the earlier lectures,
we heard about
nucleosynthesis, how
metals are formed at the centers
of stars, and 90% of all of us
is star dust.
And gravity, being
attractive, is always
trying to pull everything in,
while the pressure generated
by that nuclear energy
is pushing the star out.
It's a delicate balance that,
throughout the stars lifetime,
is able to stay.
But when the star
runs out of fuel
and loses that central support,
then gravity wins, everything
implodes, the center
collapses, and it leads
to a spectacular explosion.
That is a supernova explosion.
Again, if you were here
for Phil Pinto's talk,
I'm sure you have heard a lot
about supernova explosions.
Here is the cauldron
boiling and expelling
the outer part of the star.
And the very center right here
after that fraction of a second
leaves behind either a
neutron star or a black hole.
And the outer parts
that are expelled
make for some of the
most beautiful images,
as well as some of the nicest
science in terms of how
different elements are formed.
And this is a remnant
of a supernova explosion
several centuries
after it exploded.
And it's taken by NASA's
Chandra Space Telescope.
So in order to make more
headway between a neutron
star or black hole,
I need to tell you
what theory tells us about
what makes a neutron star
and what properties a
black hole should have.
A neutron star
can be very dense,
but it still has a surface.
There is still a force
balance between something
pushing against
gravitational attraction
and gravitational attraction.
It's not the same
balance as in the stars.
It's a lot more dense than that.
Nevertheless, there is a
surface to a neutron star.
It's also bright.
A lot of times we see the
neutron star itself glowing
in radio wavelengths, in optical
wavelengths, or in x-rays,
whereas a black hole is
always dark at the center .
Furthermore, in order to
achieve this delicate balance
between forces and
still have a surface,
a neutron star can be
no more than two times
the mass of our sun,
whereas a black hole
has to exceed that limit and
implode completely onto itself.
And it has to be more than
twice the mass of our sun.
So putting these different
pieces of information together,
all the data over
several years, we
can tell that we are looking
at a black hole in our galaxy.
In this last part of my
talk, what I would like to do
is tell you how black holes
are connected to our origins,
because perhaps I have been
able to persuade some of you
that black holes are real,
that with all our efforts
we gather the data to study
them and to understand them.
But really, this is a
series about our origins.
How are black holes, which are
thought of as death objects,
connected to our origins?
It turns out they're
connected in very many ways.
One of the ways
they are connected I
already mentioned to you.
The supernova explosions
that lead to a black hole
are the very explosions
that allow the metals that
are formed in stars to be
given back to the universe
and to foreign planets
and human beings.
But that's not it.
That's not all there is to it.
When we look further back in
the universe, what we find
is that black holes co-evolved,
evolved at the same time,
as everything else
in the universe.
For example, the very first
stars and star clusters
were very massive.
And this is what a star cluster
that got just a little bit too
heavy at the center would do.
It would collapse into a black
hole shortly after it formed.
What you see here is
that point of no return
that I talked about,
this event horizon.
And these are various
circles of light
that were shot from the
center in this calculation.
This is a real calculation
that took into account
all the interactions between
the various constituents
in this star cluster.
So what we see is that even the
very first generation of stars
must have left behind
black holes in their wake.
But that's not all
there is to it.
Everywhere we look,
there is a black hole
that co-evolved either with
its galaxy or with the stars
that form those galaxies.
So what I want to show you is
a movie from own Milky Way.
This is actually a spectacular
technological feat.
This was done with
the Keck Telescope
with the adaptive
optic system there.
And what you see is how adaptive
optics brings into focus
these various stars all the way
at the center of the Milky Way.
And on the upper
left hand side, you
will notice that
the date running
from some time in the mid '90s
to when this stops in 2006,
but we are still steadily
collecting the data in 2011.
And again, what are we doing?
We are solving the
Kepler problem.
We are tracing the stars all the
way at the center of our galaxy
in order to figure out how big
the black hole at the center
is.
And what we find is that
it's at least 4 million times
the mass of our sun.
And look at this complete
orbit as we zoom in.
These are all
various data points
that come from
different observations
of our galactic center
over many, many years.
Now how big is that orbit?
It's about 50 times the
size of our solar system.
So from the sun to
Neptune, go 50 times that,
and you have to have well
within it four million times
the mass of our sun.
And we don't see any
direct radiation from it.
So that's what makes us
think that this red cross
at the center,
which is the center
of that gravitational
system, harbors a black hole.
If we zoom out a
little bit, the region
that we just looked
at in that movie
is the one that is in
this rectangle here.
This is without adaptive optics.
And the move that
I showed you was
how this became so much
clearer when we looked
at it with adaptive optics.
Now this is our own galaxy.
Maybe we are unique in some way.
No, actually, we are
not unique in any way.
Every galaxy that we look at
has a black hole at its center.
Let me first show you
the movie that if we
were able to travel
to other galaxies
and look at their centers
what it would look like.
Now we don't have
that capability,
as I'm sure you know.
But we do have very
powerful telescopes.
And what we can do is,
with those telescopes,
zoom in to the
centers of galaxies.
What you see in this image is a
Hubble Space Telescope picture
of a nearby galaxy.
The nucleus of M84,
one of our neighbors.
What we do is put a slit through
the center of this galaxy
and we ask, is anything
swirling around that center?
And the way we would be able to
tell if something is swirling
is that light would look a
little bluer if it was coming
towards us, and it would
look a little redder
if it was going away from us.
So throughout that slit,
which going from here to here,
we can actually map what the
gas and stars and everything
around that center is doing.
And what we see is
a shape like this
that indeed looks
very blue, indicating
a very high speed with
which things are rotating
around that black hole, not
very different than the artist's
conception movie that
I just showed you,
and also receding from us.
So we find these
beautiful profiles
that tell us that
gas and stuff is just
swirling around the
center of that galaxy.
By doing that, we find
that every single galaxy
that we are able to look at
has a supermassive black hole
at its center.
Which means that the
supermassive black holes,
a million times the mass of our
sun, or up to a billion times
the mass of our sun, must
have evolved at the same time
the galaxies are evolving.
What I'm showing
you here is a movie
of how stars and
galaxies in the universe
are evolving under the
influence of gravity.
The time is running
from billions of years
ago to-- what you see here
is the redshift, which
is a indicator of time, and it
stops at about a billion years
ago.
And here what you see is how the
temperature of that gas that is
forming the stars is changing.
So what we find is that
as structure is forming,
as these individual
stars form galaxies,
they also form the black
holes at the center.
They are everywhere.
They are, in fact,
so tightly coupled
that black holes know about
the properties of the galaxy,
and the galaxy seems to
know about the properties
of the black hole, even
though the galaxy scale
is much, much larger than
the central region that
is affected by the black hole.
Remember, it's just about 50
times for our own Milky Way,
is just 50 times the
distance between the sun
and the Neptune, and
we are comparing this
to the entire
galaxy, and yet they
seem to know about
each other because they
must have co-evolved.
One of the ways in which
they must be coupled
is through how the black holes
are fed in the first place.
How did they gain weight?
How did they become
so massive as time
evolved in the universe?
So collisions between galaxies.
Which we think happen
very frequently.
Is one way in which the black
holes were fed fresh gas.
What you see here
is two galaxies
that collided into each
other, and they stripped stars
from each other.
So these are called tidal
tails because they have just
stripped all those
stars from one another,
and in the meantime,
provided a lot
of new fuel, a lot of
fresh gas into the centers
of those galaxies.
Here we're zooming
in at the center
and we're looking
at what we would
call the remnants of a merger.
And this must be
one of the ways,
even though we don't
know exactly how,
in which black holes and
galaxies could evolve.
Now that is not science fiction.
This is actually an
image of two galaxies
that must have collided.
This is the remnant of a merger.
You see one center
here, one center here.
And this is actually catching
them completely redhanded.
Lest you think that we
understand all there
is to understand about black
holes, as I already told you,
we know that every galaxy has
a supermassive black hole,
we just don't quite
understand how they
know so well about each other.
But that's just one
of the many puzzles
that blackwells present us with.
So in the last few
minutes, I want
to tell you about a couple other
puzzles that are in our future.
I could have picked a
lot of different ones,
but of course being at
the University of Arizona,
I wanted to share with you
some of the very recent results
that a team here that
I was involved in,
as well as colleagues
at Harvard University's
Center for Astrophysics,
found within this past year.
And it attracted a lot
of press attention.
So the puzzle is the following.
This is our galaxy,
somewhat schematically.
This is where the electrons
in our galaxy are.
And the red dots
represent the black holes
that we have been able to
find, weigh, and measure
the distances of.
So they may look
very few in number,
but this is not all the
black holes that we know of,
but the ones that we can
actually put on a map,
if you will.
When we look at
the sample of what
we call "confirmed" black
holes, what we noticed
is that there are none in the
sample that are less than five
times the mass of our sun.
Now if you remember
what I showed you
about outcomes of
supernova explosions,
I said less than two solar
masses, two times the mass
of our sun, makes
a neutron star,
and above two should
make a black hole.
In fact, just above two,
three, four, five solar masses
should be the most numerous type
of black hole in our galaxy.
If we look at a sample
of black hole candidates,
we should be finding
those the most.
But instead, there is
absolutely none in that sample.
So being very skeptical,
we said surely
this is because of the way
we're looking for them.
This must be what we call
an observational bias.
We are not looking
in the right places.
Perhaps we are selecting
our candidates wrong.
And we spent months trying to
understand if what we are doing
is influencing what
we are finding.
And the answer was no.
It's not that we are
looking in the wrong places.
It's not that we
are not following up
the right kind of black hole.
They really are not there,
and we don't know why.
It might be something about the
supernova explosion mechanism
we don't understand yet,
but this is something
that we would like to
explore in the coming years.
And there is one other thing
that I would like to highlight.
What you saw here is variations
on the Kepler problem, which
is a very powerful technique.
We understand the
existence of a black hole
and we can weigh it by looking
at what circles around it.
That has been
great, but we still
haven't being able to take
a picture of a black hole.
I have not been able to show
you, look, the center is dark,
and there is stuff that
is bright around it,
but we are working on it.
And one of the ways in
which we're working on it
is by looking at it with
a very particular type
of radio telescopes that are
connected throughout the world.
This is the Global Very
Large Baseline Interferometer
Array, which University
of Arizona is a part of.
In fact, we are going
to add a new telescope
to this array in
south pole so that we
can have a different type of
baseline with which we can
study the black hole at the
center of the Milky Way,
at our own galaxy.
Another way we're going to look
for it as the Giant Magellan
Telescope, which again,
the University of Arizona
is very actively
trying to build.
It is going to be cast
in our own mirror lab,
and it is going to be much
more powerful than any
of the telescopes
we have so far.
So we will be able to zoom
in even further to that event
horizon, to that central part
where everything disappears,
including light.
And finally, we also would like
to look at things in the x-rays
with higher focus.
And this is the International
X-ray Observatory
that is being proposed as a
joint mission between NASA
and the European Space Agency.
And we hope that if
and when it flies,
we are going to be able to get
x-rays very close to that event
horizon, to the center of the
black hole, beyond which they
disappear.
When that happens, I
think this is the picture
that we are going to see.
What you have here is the black
hole at the center surrounded
by not only bright emission--
in this particular picture
in x-rays-- but you also see
that gravitational lensing,
that distortion that I
was telling you about.
What you see here is the
back of the black hole that
is being lensed, and we
kind of see behind it.
You also see it
brighter on one side
and dimmer on the other side
because of that swirling motion
that I was telling you about.
So hopefully, maybe
in another 10 years,
I would love to stand
here and show you
that this is an actual
picture of a black hole
that we have taken
with the VLBI,
with the Giant
Magellan Telescope,
or with the International
X-ray Observatory,
and maybe make further
progress with our understanding
of black holes and our origins.
Thank you.
We have time for
a few questions.
[? Feryal? ?]
It seems to me that
a black hole, when
it got in front of stars,
that it would make the stars
disappear behind it as it
would pull all the light in.
Do you find that on any of
these black holes that you see?
The question is
whether stars that
happen to be behind a
black hole would disappear.
It depends on how close
they are to the black hole.
If they are in very
close proximity
and they circle the black hole,
then indeed light from them
would disappear.
And in fact, these stars that
happen to come just a little
too close to a
black hole are what
we think feeds them the
mass that they need in order
to grow.
Have we seen this real time?
No, we have not seen
it in real time.
But just the fact
that black holes,
especially at the
center of our galaxies,
have reached the sizes
that they have reached,
and the fact that
we see stars so
close to the black hole at
the center of our own galaxy,
means that some of the stars
have wandered too close,
and they have disappeared
in the black hole.
We have one more question.
Excuse me if I have made
unwarranted leap here,
but in our solar system,
if we have black holes that
are five times the solar
mass, in any other galaxy that
has the same condition, are
those related to [INAUDIBLE]?
I'm looking at the
wrong microphone.
Well, let me, if I could,
repeat the question.
So in our galaxy, we have
black holes that are five times
the mass of our sun.
Does that condition
exists in other galaxies?
Is that somehow connected
with compatibility
for life in those galaxies?
So this is a great question.
Can we also tell that black
holes in other galaxies
don't exist below five
times the mass of our sun
like we observe
them in our galaxy?
And does this tell
us anything else
about the properties
of that galaxy?
Well, unfortunately,
those smaller guys,
what we call the stellar
mass black holes, somewhere
between five times and
about 20 to 30 times
the mass of our sun, we are
quite limited in how far out we
can find them.
We know of one in the
Large Magellanic Cloud,
and we know of one in the
Small Magellanic Cloud,
but that's about as
far as we've been
able to go with our
current telescopes
in finding those smaller ones.
So the ones where a
single star circles
around them, their stellar
companion circles around them,
the data is all
from our own galaxy.
So unfortunately, we don't
know if other galaxies
have a different population
of those black holes
than ours does.
But the supermassive
ones we've seen
in many different
galaxies, including
way out in the early universe.
Would you please
elaborate on what
you mean by the black hole
at the center of the galaxy,
knowing what is going
on with the galaxy,
and the galaxy knowing
the black hole?
Would you elaborate
on that, please?
Sure.
That is one of the enigmas
of black hole science today,
and that is the relationship
between the mass
of the black hole at
the center of the galaxy
and the velocity,
the speed of stars
in the bulge of that galaxy.
The technical term
we refer to it with
is the m-sigma relation.
Sigma is the speed.
m is the mass of the black hole.
And what we find is that
stars that have nothing
to do with the vicinity of the
black hole in a given galaxy
travel at speeds that
allow us to say what
the mass of the black
hole that the center is.
So we measure them
separately, and they all
follow a well-defined relation
in hundreds of galaxies
that we look at.
Well, thank you very much
for an excellent lecture.